welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down the new horror movie
the turning the film has a big big
ending that probably left you scratching
ahead and throughout this video we'll be
giving our interpretation of it I
haven't seen anyone else drop this
theory yet so hopefully if you watched
other videos on the topic then this
helps to paint the movie in a new light
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch the film yet and don't want
anything ruined then I highly recommend
that you turn off now it's one of those
movies that you should watch with fresh
eyes so yeah this is your last chance to
turn off you're still here I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into our
breakdown of the turning
okay so the turning is actually based
loosely on the novel the turn of the
screw by author Henry James weirdly
enough this is actually the first
adaptation on the work that is due to be
released this year and haunting of Hell
House producer Mike Flanagan is
currently working on a similar property
at the moment that is the haunting of
Bly Manor which is reportedly due to be
released at the end of 2020
exclusively on Netflix similar to this
movie that series is reportedly going to
be taking elements of the book and
adapting them into its own story as for
the book itself it sent us around miles
flora and their guardian ghosts on them
miles actually dies at the end and there
are some massive subversion as to what
we see play out on screen both the book
in this film are set in black mana but
the turning of the screw explicitly
states that the ghosts are real whereas
here it is possible that it could go
either way
for this video though I'm just gonna be
giving my theory rather than diving
between the two possible scenarios think
there's a lot of evidence to back up my
analysis but obviously I'm open to you
having a completely different opinion as
mentioned oh yeah I haven't seen anyone
cover this angle in the breakdown yet
and hopefully this gives you something
new to think about if you've already
watched another one of probably a much
better youtuber than I am anyway before
we get into the interpretation though we
need to lay out the events of this story
I'm gonna be doing them in chronological
order and then we'll dive back in to
reanalyze them in order to show why
certain things happen the way that they
did the film itself predominantly
focuses on miles and flora to rich
thoroughbred orphans when they were
young their parents died in a horrendous
accident and this may or may not have
been caused by the groundskeeper Quint
that's never said in the film it's just
sort of what I picked up on and yeah it
I think it's there in the subtext flora
witnessed their deaths and this is
molded her into a shy young girl that is
afraid to leave the property in the wake
of their death Quint began to lord over
the manor walking around like he owned
the place
treating miles like his son and even
sleeping in the master bedroom this was
much to the dismay of miss Grose who had
been a member of the
on a staff for the majority of a life in
order to raise the children correctly
she reached out to a tutor named Miss
Jessel who became a sort of live-in
nanny on the grounds
Quinn became attracted here and after he
sexually assaulted her she tried to
escape the property however he managed
to catch her before she could get away
and the character murdered her and
dumped her body in a pool around the
house this is what we opened the movie
on and it pretty much sets the scene for
everything gross killed Quinton made it
look like an accident and then she
reached out to another nanny which is
where we joined Kate in 1994 Kate was
left by a father at a young age and her
mother slowly went insane now lives in a
sanitarium Kate sees a lot of her own
story in that of Flores and desperately
wants to help her after arriving at the
Manor miles returns home due to being
expelled from boarding school and slowly
he begins to annoy Kate making her life
harder and harder it becomes clear that
Quint rubbed off on him and there are
hints that he is controlling the young
boy from beyond the grave
Kate discovers miss Gesell's diary and
begins seeing ghostly apparitions of her
and Quint about the house slowly this
sensor insane and she becomes paranoid
distrustful and fearful of the property
after being haunted for days upon end
Kate receives a parcel from a mother
that is filled with what are essentially
just charcoal scribblings she slowly
begins to an earth exactly what's going
on and after a run-in with more ghosts
she discovers what happened to miss
Jessel she confronts miss gross about it
and realizes that she knew about what
Quint did and that she killed him and
made it look like an accident
the ghosts of Quint returns to kill
gross and though the spectre chases Kate
and the orphans through the house they
are able to escape however this is shown
to be just a fantasy that is triggered
by one of them others drawings and
slowly Kate descends into insanity
she begins accusing miles and flora of
lying about not seeing ghosts and then
in the final few moments spins off into
her own fantasy of being at the hospital
with her mother we see a mother is
scribbling away on the floor and she
turns around to face Kate who then
screams and we cut to black we never see
what Kate saw but this reveal was enough
to horrify her was also enough to
horrify audiences into realizing their
just wasted money
and ninety minutes of their life that
they won't be getting back anyway scrap
all that what the hell is going on well
personally I believe the entire movie is
a fantasy you bar a few key moments I
know some people think some elements of
it are real and some one are but but
overall I think that the majority of the
film takes place in Kate's head and it's
basically a reimagining of something
tragic that happened to her now I
believe that kate is actually also miss
Jessel I know you shaking your head
right now and about it hit that dislike
button but don't just yet let me explain
there's a key signifier towards this
that happens throughout the film which
I'll get into in just a bit but yeah
there's a lot of evidence for it
personally I think that miss Jessel or
Kate as I'll call her worked up by
manner and helped her raise both flora
and miles over Quint the grounds keeper
obsessed over her and one night when she
tried to escape he sexually assaulted
her I can't say the r-word because of
YouTube monetization but you know what I
mean anyway this completely broke Kate
and she fled the manor abandoning the
children their ms gross cover this up
and looked the other way
much in the same way that she often did
with Martha's behavior and thus no
justice came to Quint miss grows at one
point in the film says stop telling
tales and this shows that she might not
have believed Kate due to her regret
over leaving the children and the trauma
that she faced Kate slowly went insane I
believe that after this Kate was taken
to an asylum where she lived out the
rest of her days scribbling away and
painting seemingly nonsensical pieces of
artwork the movie is Kate in her head
living out the life that she should have
had the path that she should have taken
in which she saved the children watched
MS grosse die and escaped with them from
the clutches of Quint but what evidence
is there to support this well when we
are first introduced to Kate's mother
she hands the character a beautiful
painting of her and I believe this is
the face that she believes she now has
there's also the fact that pretty much
every time Kate sees Miss Jessel in the
movie it is through a reflective surface
she first notices the character when
slamming a window and in the reflection
of the
glass she catches a glimpse of her she
later sees a pool of water which once
more has a reflective surface and Jessel
appears in a mirror when Kate is washing
her face
Kate cannot see this and it's not like
the ghosts know the cameras are there so
so the fact that Jessel is appearing
without Kate even seeing her shows that
this could be buried within a
subconscious if it was a fantasy then
most things would have to be perfect and
nurse Quint would be dead however due to
her subconscious
he keeps creeping in at several points
and miles in my opinion is actually a
manifestation of Quint in several ways
miles wears the same clothes as Quint
and one of the times that she first
notices the ghost is when he's walking
into miles his bedroom when she is
playing the flashlight game she follows
miles downstairs and then he slowly
transforms into Quint and terrorizes her
not only does miles torment Kate
throughout the movie but he also rides a
black horse which we saw Quint doing in
a photograph Quint also died by falling
off his horse and the scene where Kay
chases miles could be similar to the
death scene that Grose apparently
carried out miles also forces himself on
Kay at one point and kisses her and
prompted to me this is a symbolism of
the sexual assault that Quint carried
out on Jessel and once more it adds to
the similarities of the character in
miles his room is also a painting with
lots of hands grabbing someone and this
happens later in the film when Kay
believes she's being attacked by the
ghostly hands of Quint could this be one
of Kate's paintings from the real world
seeping into the fantasy well personally
I believe that it is Quinn apparently
remarks on Kate's tattoo and this also
has significance the tattoo is of
Ouroboros a snake that eats itself it
shows that Kate's insanity is slowly
sending her spiraling into more madness
there's lots of evidence throughout the
film but it all points to one thing this
is Kate's fantasy the ending symbolizes
this and it's clear it's all in a head
so to reiterate Kate went through
something traumatic at the Manor and
painted out her perfect life in which
she went to the manor
watch the woman who covered up a
sexual-assault die in front of air and
saved the children that she abandoned
she sees this in the painting of the car
and then is snapped out of it and is
quickly reminded by gross that she is
completely mad it is possible that gross
could be a nurse at the hospital or a
psychiatrist that is trying to guide her
out of the fantasy this would explain
why gross opens Kate's letter before she
gives it to her and yeah it's just a fan
theory that I've come up with after
thinking on the movie for a while at the
end of the film Kate goes down to see
miles and flora and breaks Flora's doll
before claiming that she can fix it
miles says you can't fix it it's broken
and this comment is dissecting Kate
mental state showing that no matter
watch she will never get over it
she then returns to reality where she is
back at the hospital watching herself
scribble away and when the mother or
rather Kate turns around she sees her
own face and this is why she screams
that's pretty much how I took the movie
and what I think is really going on
again if you disagree with me and think
that it's the ghosts or that she was
insane or that she wasn't Jessel yeah
make sure you drop your theories below
the film is a big talking point and
every theory differs massively from the
last so yeah let me know what you
thought was going on as for the movie
itself I have to say I did feel
massively disappointed by it that would
starting off pretty strong and I had
high hopes for it due to the source
material I can't help but feel that down
the pacing was all off and too many
sequences seem to be inconsequential
looking back to the point that it made
the plot feel really Hollow I feel like
the fan theories that have come from
this film are far more interesting than
the film itself and though it has
sparked a lot of conversation it doesn't
really feel like it deserves it the
ending has only really had so much
spring from it because it's just so
ambiguous and rather than feeling
complete it feels well underdeveloped
January was turning pun intended into a
pretty good month with 1917 bad boys for
life and the gentlemen but this feels
like a dirt and I can't really recommend
it because of that I feel like I had to
make the movie better in my head in
order for it to be good and that's a big
disappointment especially from what I
was
acting mr. turnout like over all the
turning let me down and that's why it
gets a three out of ten
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts and the turning and what you
thought of the ending comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
make sure you check out our breakdown of
this weekend so the big hora release the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina we go
over everything you need to know about
part three of the show so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you massively appreciate it and it
goes a long way to making videos like
this
you get access to content early and can
also suggest video topics and breakdowns
if you want to come chat to us after the
show either follow us at definition
whitey will click the discord link in
the description below I also just wanna
let you know we're giving away a free
copy of dr. sleep to one random
subscriber all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video and leave your thoughts on the
turning in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of February and the set will be
shipped out from the enter yet surprise
so best of luck to everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
Oh